المصائب لا تاتي فرادى بعد اتهامات
الاغتصاب زوجه حكيمي تطلب الطلاق وتقارير
عن عثور ماسك على خليفه في رئاسه تويتر
ومقابله خاصه وحصريه مع نجم الدنس والمصنف
اول عالميا نوفاك
اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
مكملين معكم مشاهدينا في متابعه تطورات
الاتهام بالاغتصاب الموجهه لي اللاعب او
للاعب المنتخب المغربي ونادي باريس سان
جيرمان اشرف حكيمي ففي فتاه توجهت للشرطه
في بلاغ قالت انه مو شكوى ولكن اثبات حاله
وقالت انها بعد ما تكلموا على انستغرام
اشرف يوم 25 فبراير ارسل لها البيت وهناك
اغتصبها السلطات رغم انه البنت ما اشتكات
لكنها اعلنت فتح تحقيق قضائي في الموضوع
حكيم يرد على الاتهامات عبر بيان لمحاميته
وصف الاتهامات بالكاذبه والباطله واللي ما
صارت وبيقولوا انه مستعد للتعاون مع
السلطات وبيضع نفسه تحت تصرف العداله
نادي حكيمه اللي هو باريس سان جيرمان هو
كمان علق في اولا تم الاعلان انه هو لازال
في تشكيلات النادي وبيشارك في تدريباته
ممكن يشارك كمان في المباراه الجايه وما
في اي سبب بيمنع هذا الشيء ومصادر في
النادي قالت لوسائل اعلام فرنسيه انه
الخبر صدمها وانها جالسه بتحاول تجمع
معلومات وتفاصيل اضافيه لدعم لاعبها ضد
هذه الاتهامات وقالت انها بتثق في العداله
وانها مؤسسه تشجع الاحترام داخل وخارج
الملعب اما اللي كانت غايبه عن رده الفعل
وكل الانظار مستنيه تعليقها اصلا دون
غيرها فهي زوجه الممثله الاسبانيه هبه عبو
لمولوده لام تونسيه واب ليبي هبه التزمت
الصمت وما شفنا اي تعليق منها على صفحتها
الشخصيه لدعم ولا غيره ويبدو انه السبب في
عدم تعليقه هي الاخبار التي تم تداولها من
الاعلام الاسباني واللي قال انها طالبه
الط رسميا الاخبار بتقول انه زوجه حكيمي
من اسابيع وقبل ما يطلع موضوع الاتهامات
للعلن مقدمه رسميا اوراق الطلاق وانا
وحكيمي منفصلين من فتره والمتداول ان
ابلغت اقارب له انه علاقتهم مو زابطه بسبب
فرق العمر والاولويات فهي بتربي اولادها
وتعمل اسره وهو بس مهتم بالسهر
والانبساط هذا الكلام اللي نقلته صحيفه
فرنسيه او اسبانيه عفوا وبالنسبه للعمر
فهي 36 سنه وحكيمي 24 سنه وهم متزوجين من
ثلاث سنوات تعرفوا في 2018 وتزوجوا في
2020 وفي نفس السنه ولد اول اولادهم اللي
هو امين وفي عشرين 22 انولد الثاني واسمه
نعيم الاخبار اذا بتقول انه في انفصال من
فتره لكن يعني الاتهامات سرعت من الكشف
عنه وادله الانفصال كانت واضحه لانه اولا
الثنائي ما لهم صوره سوا على المنصات من
اكتوبر مع انه الاثنين
نشيطين جدا ثانيا ما حضرت مع حفل توزيع
جوائز ذا بيست التابع للفيفا بل راح حكيم
الحفل مع اخوه وهبه واولادها في اجازه
خارج المغرب من فتره والواقعه اللي بتتكلم
عنها البنت اللي بتتهم حكيمي صارت خلل
وجودهم خارج البلاد وفي منزلهم نفسه
[موسيقى]
حيره وفضول جداد قلبين الدنيا في اليابان
وسبب العثور على جسم غريب جديد في احد
الكهوف على الساحل كميزو
الجسم مثل ما شفته هو كره عملاقه حديديه
لونها برتقالي او يمكن اللون كده من الصدا
او قطرها واحد ونصف متر وثقيله الوزن ومثل
ما شفنا فيها النتوءات واضحه واللي لقيوها
قالوا انه خبطوا عليها وطلعت صوت باكد
انها جوفاء وبلغوا السلطه لو حاسين انكم
سمعتوا مشاهدين الخبر من قبل ترى مو
غلطانين انا نفسي حسيت بهذا الشيء لانه من
عشره ايام نقلنا خبر بس احنا العالم كله
يعني نقلوه اتكلم عن العثور السكان في احد
الشواطئ على كره عملاقه ضخمه مجهوله
المصدر وجات الشرطه وطوقت المكان ومنعت
الحركه وجابوا فرق هندسيه وفرق متفجرات
علشان يتطمنوا ايش هذه الكره
الناس بعد ما انتشرت الصور والمقاطع بدات
تكهناتها وبدا اللي يقول مرساوي اللي يقول
فضلات شي مرمي في البحر واللي يقول هذا
اكيد شايف فضائي واللي يقول وسيله تجسس
الصينيه والسلطات ما بتاكد ولا في شيء وفي
الاخر وبعد كثير جدا الشرطه المحليه قالت
يا جماعه ترى طلعت عوامه ارساء تحررت من
مرساها بفعل عاصفه ضخمه او انه تم سحبها
من قبل سفينه صيد كبيره وتم ازالتها من
على الشاطئ اقيل ان السلطات راح تحتفظ
فيها الفتره بعدين ترميها الناس الان
مستنيه تشوف الجديده هذه ايش يعني لو
عوامه في النهايه في الكهف حيشوفوا
[موسيقى]
هو احد الاشخاص اللي بيشتغلوا مع ماسك من
سنوات في عشرين او في 2003 انضم لسبيس اكس
وحاليا هو الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه
من سنه كمان بيساعدوا في تويتر والساعات
الماضيه اسم ستيف متداول جدا في الاخبار
والسبب تقارير بتقول انه ماسك خلاص اختاره
علشان يخلفوا في رئاسه تويتر ماسك لو
فاكرين من اشهر اعلن انه راح يتنحى عن هذا
المنصب ويدور على شخص مجنون كفايه عشان
يتولى الاداره ومن كم اسبوع انسال عن
الموضوع في قمه الحكومات في دبي انه من
متى او انه متى حيتنحى عن رئاسه تويتر
فقال انه قريبا وغالبا قبل اخر السنه ومن
وقتها والتساؤلات شغاله عن هويه رئيس
تويتر الجديد التقارير الحاليه بترجح انه
هو الشخص المختار وبتقول انه صار له سنه
شغال مع ماسك عن قرب في تويتر وبتسميه
كمان مهندس التسريحات
تويتر تلقوا مكالمات من ديفيز قبل طرح
خلالها عليهم اسئله عن الموظفين
والمتميزين من الموظفين المتميزين تحديدا
والاداء العام للموظفين وفكروا انه يعني
المدراء بيسالوا عشان المكافات لكن يعني
هم
المكافات لكن اتضح انه لا انه هو كان
بيسال كده عشان وقتها كانت فتره التسريح
من الوظائف على العموم خلينا نرجع كمان في
بعض المعلومات اللي طلعت انه كمان ماسك
كلف وبتخفيض 500 مليون دولار من التكاليف
لكن اشتغل على تخفيض مليار دولار عن طريق
انهاء بعض العقود مع شركات خارجيه
والتفاوض على البعض الاخر هذا غير انه هو
بينام في المكتب في بقر الشركه وكل هذه
الاشياء خلت التكهنات بانه هو اللي راح
يكون الرئيس التنفيذي القادم للتويتر
في رجل صيني اسمه ليو هربان من الشرطه من
14 سنه ومتخبي في كهف ضمن غابه ولكنه
اخيرا مل من حياه الهاربين وسلم نفسه
للشركه لانه يبغى يعيش حياه طبيعيه مثل
مثل غيره مو هنا القصه القصه ايش السبب
اللي خلاه يهرب ويتخبى في كهف وسط الغابه
14 سنه هذا اللي راح يصدمكم فعلا ويمكن ما
تصدقون السبب انه لي وقت كان عمره في
الثلاثينات شارك في عمليه سطو على محطه
وقود هو وصهر وشريك ثالث وسرقوا من المحطه
مبلغ
يا جماعه 23 دولار
نعم 23 دولار هذا المبلغ الكامل بس وقت ما
تعرفوا كمان المبلغ اللي طلع له لحاله من
كل السرقه يمكن تنهاره فمن بعد ما اكلوا
وشربوا واشتروا العاب ناريه طلع لكل واحد
منهم اربعه دولارات الحمد لله ومن بعدها
رجعوا للبيت لكن الشرطه قبضت على صهره
وشريكم الثالث علشان كذا الاخ ليو هرب على
الغابه وسكن في كهف 14 سنه وكان بيتسل
عشان يشوف اهله وياخد اكل وشرب وبعد 14
سنه من الحبس اللي هو حبس نفسه بنفسه في
مثل ما شايفين وعلى فكره كل اللي عمله في
نفسه هذا وسنوات الهروب هذه كلها الطويله
ما حتخليه ينفذ من العقوبه لانه لسه بوجه
عقوبه يمكن توصل لعشر سنين سجن يعني لو
كان حبيبي من وقت اسلم نفسه كان اهون عليه
من السجن مرتين له 14 سنه وعشر سنين تانيه
يعني
مشهد مرعب متداول اونلاين من داخل طائره
تعرضت لبرق ومطبات هوائيه فهبطت الف قدم
مره واحده
الطائره كانت متجه من اصل امريكا الى
فرانكفورت المانيا رحله المفروض مدتها 11
ساعه تقريبا لكن بعد ثلاث ساعات اضطرت
تهبط اضطراري في واشنطن العاصمه من بعد
برق ومطبات هوائيه فجائيه ضربت الطائره
وخلتها وهي على ارتفاع 37 الف قدم تنزل
فجاه الف قدم وتطلعهم تاني
متخيلين السرعه يعني قوه الخبطه كل هذا
صار فجاه ودون سابق انذار ومن غير ما
الطيار يكون منور اصلا اشاره لبس الاحزمه
وعشان كده اللي ما كان حاطط حزام تاذم ومن
بعد الهبوط الاضطراري تم نقل سبعه ركاب
للمستشفى باصابات مختلفه والسلطات بدات
تحقق في اللي صار
[موسيقى]
والله
امين
[موسيقى]
وانا
يعني
[موسيقى]
الندى
كده
[موسيقى]